THIS WILL SHOCK YOUR CONSCIENCE.
FIRST, WE START AT THE VERY TOP,
HOUSE SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI FOR
WEEKS, THE SPEAKER TRYING TO
PLAY PETTY, POLITICAL GAMES WITH
THIS NATION ANY STATE OF THE
UNION ON THE PRESIDENT -- BY THE
WAY, WHAT IS SHE FIGHTING FOR?
THE PRESIDENT'S FIGHTING LIFE
AND DEATH.
THE PRESIDENT IS FIGHTING SAFETY
AND SECURITY.
SHE HAS BARRED THE PRESIDENT
FROM PERFORMING HIS
CONSTITUTIONAL DUTY IN THE HOUSE
CHAMBER, MAKING HER THE FIRST
SPEAKER IN U.S. HISTORY TO EVER
DO SO.
SHE REFUSED TO COMPROMISE ON
BUDGET NEGOTIATIONS, WOULDN'T
EVEN COME TO THE TABLE TO TALK
ABOUT ANY KIND OF DEAL.
SHE HAS BEEN TOO BUSY ON A
LUXURIOUS VACATION, OTHER
DEMOCRATS ON A LOBBYIST PAID
JUNKET, AGAIN, LUXURIOUS
LOCATIONS AND RESORTS.
PLANNING TAXPAYER-FUNDED
EXCURSIONS AROUND THE GLOBE.
TO EVEN TALK TO THE PRESIDENT,
OFFER DRAMATIC COMPROMISES,
THINGS SHE HAS THAT OVER THE
YEARS SHE WANTS, SHE HAS NO TIME
FOR THAT.
TONIGHT, THE PRESIDENT GOES
ABOVE HER BITTER, PETTY,
PARTISAN GAMESMANSHIP.
HE POSTPONED THE STATE OF THE
UNION.
SOME SEEMED UPSET BY THIS, THEY
WANTED HIM TO GO TO AN
ALTERNATIVE LOCATION, BUT I
THINK IT IS A BAD IDEA.
WHY?
BECAUSE THE PRESIDENT, TO GIVE
UP THE GRANDEUR, GIVING THE
STATE OF THE UNION IN THE HOUSE
CHAMBER "MR. SPEAKER, THE
PRESIDENT OF UNITED STATES."
THAT IS A POWERFUL MOMENT.
CONGRESSMEN AND WOMEN, SENATORS,
LITERALLY STAKING OUT THEIR
SEATS SO THEY CAN SHAKE THE
PRESIDENT'S HAND 14 HOURS AHEAD
OF TIME.
NO OTHER PLACE CAN MATCH THAT
SYMBOLIC LOCATION.
THE GRANDEUR, AND THIS PRESIDENT
DESERVES NOTHING LEFT.
I'M SURE THAT WILL HAPPEN IN THE
NEAR FUTURE.
THIS IS ABOUT SO MUCH MORE THAN
POLITICS.
THIS IS ABOUT YOUR SAFETY, YOUR
SECURITY, THIS IS ABOUT THE
SAFETY OF THE COUNTRY, AND
LITERALLY LIFE-AND-DEATH.
THIS IS ABOUT A PRESIDENT
FULFILLING A PROMISE TO SECURE
OUR SOUTHERN BORDER.
AT THIS ABOUT SAVING AMERICAN
LIVES THAT ARE IMPACTED BY GANGS
LIVES THAT ARE IMPACTED BY GANG,
CARTELS, DRUGS, VIOLENCE.
IT IS LIFE-AND-DEATH.
PEOPLE ARE DYING.
90% OF THAT HEROIN THAT GETS
INTO THIS COUNTRY COMES FROM
THAT BORDER.
IT IS ABOUT 10,000 NEW MIGRANTS
NOW OBTAINING VISAS FROM THE
GOVERNMENT OF MEXICO TO TRAVEL
THROUGH THE COUNTRY IN ORDER TO
MAKE THEIR WAY NORTH.
INTO OUR COUNTRY.
BECAUSE WE HAVE UNSECURED
BORDERS.
NOW WHEN THE U.S. GOVERNMENT IS
REOPENED, THE PRESIDENT WILL
HOLD A STATE OF THE UNION WHERE
IT BELONGS, IN THE HOUSE
CHAMBERS, WITH MEMBERS OF BOTH
PARTIES, HOPEFULLY, PRESIDENT.
IN THE MEANTIME, THE SHUTDOWN
DOES CONTINUE, THE PRESIDENT HAS
BEEN UNRELENTING, FIGHTING TO
MAKE THE COUNTRY SAFER.
DEMOCRATS CONTINUE TO FEED THEIR
INSATIABLE APPETITE, THIS
PATHOLOGICAL HATRED, THIS
DIVISION THAT THEY HAVE, AND OF
COURSE, IT IS ALWAYS ABOUT A
DESIRE FOR POWER.
BREAKING TONIGHT, THE
WHITE HOUSE IS REPORTEDLY NOW
DRAFTING A NATIONAL EMERGENCY
ORDER, ALLOCATING $7 BILLION FOR
THAT WALL THAT WOULD REQUIRE
ZERO CONGRESSIONAL APPROVAL.
A TODAY THE PRESIDENT REASSURED
AMERICANS THAT HE WILL GET
GUARANTEED FUNDS FOR THE WALL
ONE WAY OR ANOTHER.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> President Trump: ONE OF THE
IDEAS SUGGESTED, THEY PAY A
PRORATED DOWN PAYMENT FOR THE
WALL, WHICH I THINK THE PEOPLE
AGREE THAT YOU NEED, YOU NEED
THE WALL.
I HAVE OTHER ALTERNATIVES IF I
HAVE TO, I WILL USE THOSE
ALTERNATIVES IF I HAVE TO.
WE WANT TO GO THROUGH THE
SYSTEM.
WE HAVE TO HAVE A WALL IN THIS
COUNTRY.
WE HAVE CRIMINALS POURING INTO
OUR COUNTRY.
WE HAVE NO CHOICE BUT TO HAVE A
WALL OR A BARRIER.
IF WE DON'T HAVE THAT, IT IS
JUST NOT GOING TO WORK.
>> Sean: AGAIN, I ASKED, WHAT
IS NANCY PELOSI FIGHTING FOR?
WHAT IS IN THE BEST INTEREST OF
THE COUNTRY?
PRESIDENT TRUMP REMAINS READY,
WILLING TO NEGOTIATE WITH
DEMOCRATIC LEADERSHIP.
THE WHITE HOUSE DOORS ARE WIDE
OPEN, HE IS WILLING TO
COMPROMISE AS HE HAS SHOWN TIME
AND AGAIN.
HE IS EVEN WILLING TO TAKE A
PRORATED FUNDING RATE FOR THE
WALL FOR A SHORT PERIOD OF TIME.
GIVE CONGRESS ANOTHER CHANCE TO
DO THEIR JOB AND FIND A
RESOLUTION.
IF THE STALEMATE CONTINUES, IT
IS OBVIOUS, DEMOCRATS OR FEELS
TO COME TO THE TABLE.
THE PRESIDENT IS CLEAR, HE WILL
DECLARE A NATIONAL EMERGENCY AND
SOLVE THE PROBLEM HIMSELF.
IT MAY TAKE TIME TO FIGHT IN THE
COURTS, BUT IN MY OPINION, HE
WILL WIN.
BY THE WAY, THAT WILL HAPPEN.
UNFORTUNATELY, AS WE SHOWED YOU
LAST NIGHT, NANCY PELOSI SEEMS
TO BE STANDING FOR NOTHING BUT
BEING AGAINST US BEFORE.
IN THE HEIGHT OF BUDGET
NEGOTIATIONS, SHE AND OTHER TOP
DEMOCRATS TRIED TO SLIP AWAY FOR
THE SEVEN DAYS OVERSEE JUNKET
COURTESY OF VIEW, THE TAXPAYERS.
OF COURSE, NOTHING NEW FOR
PELOSI, LOOK AT THIS.
ACCORDING TO DIGITAL WATCH, HER
LAST TERM AND SPEAKER, SHE
RACKED UP A MASSIVE TRAVEL BILL.
WITH THE U.S. AIR FORCE, OVER A
TWO YEAR PERIOD, SHE SPENT MORE
THAN $2 MILLION OF YOUR MONEY ON
AIR TRAVEL, 100,000 OF WHICH WAS
IN-FLIGHT EXPENSES.
THAT MEANS FOOD AND BOOZE, ALL
OF THE POLITICIANS WORKING SO
HARD, HALF OF THE YEAR.
THANKFULLY, THE PRESIDENT PUT
THE KIBOSH ON HER MOST RECENT
OVERSEAS JUNKET, AND TODAY WE
DID SEND FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR,
LAWRENCE JONES, TO THE STREETS
OF NEW YORK CITY TO SEE WHAT
AMERICANS REALLY THINK ABOUT THE
RADICAL, EXTREME, SOCIALIST,
DEMOCRATIC SPEAKER,
NANCY PELOSI, AT HER SO-CALLED
LEADERSHIP.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE FIRST PRESIDENT IN
AMERICAN HISTORY TO BE
DISINVITED FROM THE STATE OF THE
UNION.
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT THAT?
>> I CAN'T BELIEVE IT.
>> DO YOU FEEL LIKE IT IS
DISGRACEFUL?
SPEAKER ABSOLUTELY.
I CANNOT BELIEVE THAT EVER
HAPPENED.
IN THE UNITED STATES.
TO CANCEL SOMETHING BECAUSE OF
YOUR POLITICS, YOU ARE NOT
HELPING ANYONE.
YEAH, IT'S WRONG.
>> I THINK NANCY PELOSI IS DOING
THE RIGHT THING BECAUSE
DONALD TRUMP'S DAY TRYING THIS
COUNTRY.
BY HIS RHETORIC AND HIS RACISM,
AND A MILLION OTHER THINGS, AND
I THINK NANCY PELOSI IS THE
VOICE OF REASON IN THIS COUNTRY.
>> DO YOU FEEL NANCY PELOSI WAS
WRONG?
>> YES.
I BELIEVE THE PRESIDENT SHOULD
BE ATTEND.
IT SHOULD BE HIS CHOICE WHETHER
HE WANTS TO ATTEND OR NOT
ATTEND.
>> WHAT HE IS DOING TO THIS
COUNTRY IS AN ABOMINATION, AND
PEOPLE'S RIGHTS, HUMAN RIGHTS
ARE BEING VIOLATED.
>> WHAT HUMAN RIGHTS ARE BEING
VIOLATED?
>> WHAT HUMAN RIGHTS?
UM, THE LIST GOES ON AND ON.
>> SHE SAID THIS WAS BECAUSE OF
SECURITY, BUT THEY SAY THAT IS
NOT TRUE.
DID SHE LIVE?
SPEAKER SHE SAID SHE HAD
SECURITY CONCERNS, WHICH I
BELIEVE, SHE PROBABLY DOES.
>> SHE DIDN'T TALK TO THE
NECESSARY PEOPLE TO FIGURE THAT
OUT.
>> IT DOESN'T MATTER.
>> DO YOU THINK IT IS ERODING
THE INSTITUTION?
THIS DOESN'T MEAN YOU AGREE WITH
THE PRESIDENT ON EVERYTHING, BUT
THIS IS A REPORT CARD TO THE
COUNTRY INTO CONGRESS, RIGHT?
>> IT LOOKS CHILDISH, YOU KNOW,
AND I BELIEVE IT WAS A TERRIBLE
THING THAT NANCY PELOSI DID TO
THE PRESIDENT, FOR HER TO CANCEL
THAT AND GO AGAINST THE SPEAKS
VOLUMES.
>> THAT'S A REALLY GOOD
QUESTION.
[LAUGHTER]
>> DO YOU THINK NANCY PELOSI TO
TAKE A MEETING WITH THE
PRESIDENT?
>> SHE SHOULD, THAT IS HER JOB.
DO YOUR JOB.
JUST DO YOUR JOB!
>> Sean: A GOOD QUESTION.
WHAT HUMAN RIGHTS ARE BEING
VIOLATED?
UM, THEY ARE BEING VIOLATED,
WHATEVER THEY ARE.
YOU CAN'T MAKE THIS UP.
OF COURSE, THAT IS
NEW YORK CITY.
CALIFORNIA, NEW YORK, NOT
EXACTLY REPRESENTING RED STATE
AMERICA.
ANYWAY, SADLY, NANCY AND CHUCK
ARE NOW BEING CONTROLLED BY THE
MOST RADICAL, MOST EXTREME
ELEMENTS IN THE NEW SOCIALIST
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THESE ARE THE SAME FAR LEFT
INDIVIDUALS NOW PLAYING
KINGMAKERS IN THE UPCOMING 2020
PRESIDENTIAL PRIMARY.
THAT BRINGS US TO TONIGHT'S
"HANNITY WATCH," REPORT ON THE
2020 RACE, WE SEE NEARLY EVERY
SINGLE DEMOCRAT ANNOUNCING HER
CANDIDACY, THE FIRST THING THEY
DO, I'VE GOT TO APOLOGIZE FOR
THIS POSITION I HAD THAT MAY
SOUND CONSERVATIVE, OR YOU WILL
HATE ME.
KIRSTEN GILLIBRAND, SHE
APOLOGIZED FROM ONE SUPPORTING
THE SECOND AMENDMENT.
THEN YOU HAVE ANOTHER
APOLOGIZING FOR THE MIXED TRACK
RECORD ON SOCIAL ISSUES, SOMEHOW
STILL WAITING ON ELIZABETH
WARREN'S APOLOGY FOR FAKING AND
BENEFITING FROM A LIE AND SAYING
SHE IS A NATIVE AMERICAN.
MORAN DID, HOWEVER, FIND TIME TO
PROPOSE BRAND-NEW TAXES, RIGHT
THERE, CHECK IT OUT.
SHE IS ALWAYS FINDING NEW AND
CREATIVE WAYS TO PICK YOUR
POCKET AND PENALIZE AMERICANS
THAT SHE DESCRIBES AS WEALTHY.
SOMEHOW, SHE WANTS TO TAKE THAT
MONEY AND REDISTRIBUTE IT.
MEANWHILE, ONE OF WARREN'S
PRIMARY OPPONENTS,
SENATOR KAMALA HARRIS IS
SPENDING HER TIME RAISING AN
ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF MONEY, BUYING
UP ALL OF THE FACEBOOK ADS THAT
SHE CAN FIND, AND OF COURSE,
TRASHING THE PRESIDENT.
SHE WANTS HIM TO OPEN UP
TRUMP TOWER AS A SHELTER TO THE
VICTIMS OF THE SHUTDOWN.
THERE ARE OTHER PEOPLE THAT OWN
THOSE UNITS, HE ACTUALLY SOLD
THEM.
THEY ARE NOT HIS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> PEOPLE ARE WORRIED ABOUT
EVICTION.
LISTEN, YOU KNOW WHAT I THINK
SHOULD HAPPEN?
IF THE PRESIDENT FEELS THAT
STRONGLY ABOUT IT, OPEN UP THE
TRUMP TOWER AND LET EVERYBODY
LIVE IN THEIR RENT FREE, AND
MAYBE WE CAN START HAVING A
DISCUSSION.
HE'S GOT SOME ROOM!
>> FEBRUARY 1ST IS GOING TO BE
RENT TODAY FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE
RELYING ON -- SUPPOSED TO BE A
GOOD JOB.
>> Sean: KAMALA HARRIS IS A
MEMBER OF CONGRESS, SHE CAN OPEN
UP HER HOME.
A NANCY PELOSI IS A
MULTI-MULTI-MILLIONAIRE.
WHY DON'T WE SEND THEM TO HER
DISTRICTS?
NEEDLES, FECES, HOMELESS PEOPLE
EVERYWHERE.
WHY DOESN'T SHE BUILD A HOMELESS
SHELTER THERE?
THAT'S RIGHT, THEY ARE ONLY
GENEROUS WITH YOUR MONEY.
LIKE YOU SAID, IT IS NOT A
JOKING MATTER IN THE SENSE.
IN THE COMING WEEKS, THIS CROP